yeah you are a fan of British television
which seems very unlikely but you come
here and you you like we all should
watch it I understand the woman likes it
how they do the like when like itv2 when
they do the coming up next on itv2 very
excited about what's coming up next go
to the next channel and then I wait for
it to come around again that's my
favorite thing about British television
I think you're doing your first solo
tour which is a big big deal ya know I'm
really excited I
yeah I'm really excited it's my first
time doing a tour by myself and I feel
like that's the best you know
manifestation of songs were you going on
your tour why I'm coming here in June
which is really exciting
you're off in Glasgow I believe yeah
yeah yeah in at the deep end a good
British accent I think we're coming up
on itv2 is very good
that's excellent you want to hear it
again do the itv2 accent again we'll
find out coming up Camilla yeah I don't
wanna get it wrong now of it being so
good no you're killing me
[Applause]
[Music]